want to go back to the first little
snippet that we played yeah where bruce
arian says everyone was handing us the
lombardi in august he said something
similar to that to tracy wolfson of cbs
i caught her report during the game
yesterday hey hey bruce that's an
argument you make in august you you
wrapped your arms and legs around that
back in august nobody from the
buccaneers was saying whoa
hey whoa
don't be handing us the lombardi now we
haven't proven anything yet they loved
that then because they thought that's
where they were heading people believed
it and they didn't do anything to pull
the bar down just like the browns of
2019 the bar is high fine with us yeah
right now that they're not making it
over the bar well well oh the bar was
too high don't tell me that in late
november bruce you tell me that in
august when people are putting the bar
that high well hey uh you know it's it's
after a game frustration it's a little
bit probably frustrating i said it
before the game too i said before the
game this is his new this is his new
thing mantra oh you gave us the lombardi
back in august well you kept your mouth
shut about it back in august and we know
that bruce aries isn't bashful about
opening his mouth so he should have said
then we're getting ahead of ourselves
they believed it back then they don't
believe it now that's the difference
well yeah they're feeling the pressure
that's what i was going to say you know
that yeah you lose yesterday and that
pressure and then you're feeling the
pressure of being in seven and five
right with all that talent they have on
the football team and tom brady and all
the talk so i'm sure there's a little
uneasiness down there as you could see i
mean i i don't think there's any doubt
about that expectation levels are high
it still seems they're like a team
that's
kind of
just you know a work in progress again
it was another one of those offensive
showings where you were just like okay
there was some really bad there was some
really good and there was some in
between um
but yeah they're they didn't expect to
be sitting here seven and five right now
towards the bottom of the nfc you know
playoff picture and you know of course
going into a bye week having to fight
here the last four games of the year
yeah that's absolutely right seven and
five they get a late buy they are
out of it for all practical purposes in
the nfc south the question is can they
hold on to the five the six or the seven
and get to the playoffs and it looks
like they should be able to but who
knows at this point who knows what's
going to happen over the course of the
next two weeks one of the things that
bruce aryan said yesterday on the way
out the door for the bye week we got to
be careful with the virus because once
you set guys out to the community for a
few days they may come back positive and
you may have a problem at a time when
the numbers are off the charts and
nobody really seems to notice nobody
really seems to care bruce arians
notices and he cares because it may
affect his ability to field a football
team yeah in two weeks when they take on
the vikings who may be six and six if
they beat the jaguars will be six and
six and then position to catch catch the
buccaneers in the playoff chase so that
next game which looked like a gimme it
looked like a check the box it looked
like a no big deal that's got the
potential to be a a mid-december playoff
game it it definitely does they they've
put them in a little bit of a tough spot
here as far as where they were to where
they are now i mean losing three out of
the last four football games and uh not
playing up to the level we saw maybe you
know when they were blowing out the
raiders and green bay packers and
everybody like that but you know uh
atlanta the way they're planned to have
to play them twice down the stretch you
know matt ryan raheem morris they're not
going to go down easily in that one you
know so there are some you know
intriguing matchups here but yeah that
minnesota vikings one whoa vikings win
like you said now they're both seven and
six if the vikings could upset tampa and
pull that off uh we wouldn't expect that
so it's gonna be interesting but the
bucks not playing good football right
now and they deserve to be right in that
little you know spot they are we saw
yesterday it's a tale of two teams and
you just don't know what you're gonna
get out of them right now depending on
which half which quarter or whatever
part of the game it is the good news for
the buccaneers when they return to
action the vikings do not have patrick
mahomes and tyree kill the bad news for
the buccaneers the chiefs did and they
made repeated use of that combination my
goodness mahomes and tyrique three
touchdowns it could have been worse over
200 receiving yards in the first quarter
for tyree kill he finished with 269 i
mean we were looking up the all-time
single game record flipper anderson 336.
we thought that was in jeopardy
yesterday and it was for a while it just
petered out and that's the thing about
the chiefs we talked about this last
night chris they flipped the switch on
they flipped the switch off and you
don't have to have it on for very long
to win a game but my god if they could
just keep it going for all four quarters
they could score 100 points oh no
there's no doubt there was yards and
points left all over that field last
night i mean as impressive as a game as
it was for patrick mahomes 37 to 49 462.
it should have been like
43 of 54 for 500 he could have broke the
record last night is what i'm trying to
say he had a chance to break the
all-time passing record but to your your
point they went through a just they fell
asleep and you know that to me
is the frustrating thing about the
chiefs to what you're saying i mean a
little bit we see this all the time
these explosions and then these dull
moments and last night i mean
with danger once again there you know in
a 425 game and and to me like i get all
these texts during the game like you
know from friends who are ex-football
buddies damn
the chiefs defense can they close a game
out it's not on the chiefs defense to
close the game out there's nine zillion
dollars on the offense of the chiefs
they're supposed to close games out it's
their job when you got your foot on
their throat there's 27-10 and mccole
hardman's wide open going down the
middle of the field you know that that's
the point where you go all right yeah
our defense isn't great but our offense
is so great that we're just going to put
our defense in a spot here where they
can't even mess it up and you can't make
a game of it saying it is frustrating
but damn i don't know they always answer
the bell when they need to right oh okay
we need a few first downs and we haven't
done anything no problem we'll get a few
first downs game will be over uh but
yeah i want to see that maximum
potential like you're talking about
yeah and and look that did give the
opening to the buccaneers and to their
credit they they did what they had to do
to try to make a game of it it all just
kind of felt like it was in slow motion
everyone was sleepwalking especially the
chiefs after that point and to your
point patrick homes really could have
ended up with the single game record i
know who holds the single game record do
you know oh um hold on i want to say
it's norm van brocklin at like 561.
five five four norm van brockman
september 28 1951
and and he here's what's also impressive
the uh the 500 club yeah mahomes isn't
in that right there's a there's a guy
there's a guy here sims yeah big fan
bill sims big phil had one bill sims in
the 500 club
5 13. 5 13 in 1985 yeah i know some some
big numbers there but uh yeah i think he
had two weeks in a row where he went for
like 4 30 and 5 14 back to back weeks
but yes i mean to your point i mean we
were both watching the game together
there was just there was a lot of plays
where you just go oh oh oh oh my gosh
office fingertips oh that's on my
unbelievable he really did he had a
chance to break that record last night
but they kind of lost their
concentration as they always do
and then just regained it when they
needed to as always and come through in
the end of the football game
one of the reasons why the numbers were
so astronomical early for tyree kill
the buccaneers made the rare and there's
a reason why it's rare decision to cover
tyree kill one-on-one here's bruce
arians after the game talking about that
failed strategy
he had a man a man you know we tried to
get a safety to him if we could you know
he got kelsey on the other side too so
it's a lot of weapons but when we did
play man-to-man uh patrick found him and
they made some really good plays
[Music]
oh yes they did and and and look that's
the challenge for any offense that has a
weapon like tyreek hill anytime you see
him man-to-man you got to get the ball
to him and and
aryans is right if you put too much
emphasis on
tyree kill
you're letting travis kelsey beat you
and that may be one of the reasons now
skill and ability is one of the reasons
as well but if if they're always
sliding the coverage over the hill it's
going to open things up for travis
kelsey so you pick your poison and and
look that's that's the reality though
you know that the
chiefs are going to score their points
and at the end of the day the fact they
only had 27 i mean if you tell the bucks
going into the game you're going to hold
yeah cheese to 27 they say we'll take
that let's just go try to score 30. no
you're you're right i mean and hey it
was there to be had the buccaneers they
moved the ball consistently you know the
second half we saw the two turnovers
from brady right when he got a little
pressure in his face
both interceptions but on both of those
drives they were moving the ball there
too
you know and and you know as far as
playing man-to-man in that conversation
with tyree kill
i there's only
i've really only seen one human on earth
that can really do that that was jaylen
ramsey he's the only guy i've seen that
can go toe-to-toe with him and tyree
kill just won't absolutely go off he
might get four catches for 65 yards but
he won't do what you saw there last
night that is ridiculous you know the
leap carlton davis in some of those
positions that they left him and i don't
care who it is there's just no way he
can win that there has to be
the x's and the o's yeah the x's oh we
got him covered he didn't look good
yeah it looked good on the board it's 24
you got 10 okay we're shirt up there
let's move on
but
but there has to be something else and
you know the teams that always dabble in
man-to-man and things like that okay you
can leave a guy man-to-man but as we've
seen like with the new england patriots
and their attack against mahomes and the
chiefs you know okay it's single safety
it's man-to-man but the single safety is
always aware
that oh wait i got tyree kill man-to-man
here let me help that corner out by body
presence or being closer to him
to just scare away mahomes from that
match-up and just there was none of that
it was like hey carlton davis you're a
good football player we think you're
darrell rivas in his prime apparently go
out there and cover him all over the
field and that's just not possible with
that human being because how many
rockets does tyree he'll have up his
butt
well if three is the maximum i'd say
three and a half okay yes all right you
might have three with a little turbo
boost in there yeah
uh
okay the buccaneers offense ultimately
did wake it up and one thing that's
encouraging i saw mike evans catching a
couple of touchdown passes when the game
seemed to be out of reach 27-10 last two
scores of the game 31 yarder from brady
seven yarder from brady and you know
they
you know what if if you're trying
as a bucks fan
or just an eternal optimist if you're
trying to come out of this game glass
half full offensively what's what's
what's the case you make to the bucks as
to why they should feel good going into
their buy well no you're you're sitting
down there
27 10 and you're going oh man it looks
like we're done we're in trouble this
one's over
and all of a sudden they kind of get in
a rhythm with the touchdown you know at
the end of the first half field goal to
start the second half you know we talked
about the two interceptions you're
moving the ball but then late in the
game i mean right down the field right
down the field on two touchdown drives
where you're going hey if my homes and
company don't get the ball if they don't
get first downs here
the chiefs have shown no signs of
slowing down the bucks here the last few
drives they're gonna go down the field
and at least kick a field goal if not
score a touchdown so again with the
bucks
you know they're a little bit
frustrating too we see these glimmers of
going
wow okay this is the team i like this is
what we this is awesome to watch there's
just so many peaks and valleys right now
and i go back to the same thing again
i gotta watch the game back on film
we're getting ready for a show we're
watching that and all these other games
but i just thought
once again when they get out of their
shotgun spread it out mode
and that's what i felt like i saw a
little more in the second half is again
the tight ends the ronald jones just a
little running game oh gronkowski on
deep crosses play action pass things
like that that to me is when they're
really effective and they can play with
anybody but i just don't know is it
brady or bruce ahrens he wants to get in
this shotgun spread and throw the ball
all over the field and play this four
and five yard dink and dunk thing and
they're not built like that
and honestly brady's not good enough to
where he's just gonna carry the team
like that against all teams every week
every week every week
and uh that would be the silver lining
to me with the bucks is that look at
that offense in the second half
they do have to figure out what they are
and who they are that's it they plan to
be right offensively and last week i'm
sorry i love bruce arians and and he's
deserved all the accolades he's gotten
he should have been a head coach a lot
earlier in his career one of the reasons
he wasn't is he doesn't play the game he
doesn't kiss but and look i respect that
he's always true to himself he's always
authentic but this brady thing has
really exposed some flaws in how to
handle a superstar and he's had
superstars in the past
and like last week we we get we get the
the the criticism the open criticism of
brady we get the passive aggressive
stuff you got byron leftwich jumping on
with the thanksgiving day press
conference saying
our offense is the quarterback and the
quarterback is the offense it's all him
everyone's saying it's him it's him it's
him it's tom it's what he wants it's
what he likes but we're not seeing what
he likes we're seeing him doing
something that belongs to someone else's
offense and then brady gets a chance to
meet with reporters and this came on
friday and now nobody really put on the
t the opportunity for him
to respond right to what's you know
seems to be fairly constant criticism
from aryans but
brady shoulders the responsibility he
doesn't try to push the blame to someone
else now it may have reached a little
bit of a critical mass from the
standpoint of trying you know to draw
brady out yesterday here's the question
the answer that ultimately caused his
press conference after the game to be
two minutes and 21 seconds long we'll
let you hear it and we'll react to it on
the other side
there's been some folks that have had
some chatter about you know you still
look like you're running someone else's
offense one of your former teammates
even said on tv that he thinks that you
need a new head coach what do you make
of all that noise
no it's just the external noise that
when you're losing you know that's what
you deal with so
uh
you know i love playing for for the guys
that i play with the coaches the whole
organization's been unbelievable and i
think what uh
you know it's got to go out and i
certainly have to do a better job the
last four weeks of the year
so appreciate it let's have a good week
there were other reporters queued up and
ready to go and they weren't happy that
tommy walked away when he did and look
yes there's always going to be external
noise if you're losing but
he had 20 years in new england when
his coach
did not add
to the external noise with internal
fodder for the external noise to get
louder and louder when brady had a
particularly bad game in 2014 against
the kansas city chiefs he seemed chiefs
different quarterback yeah but even
worse result embarrassment on monday
night football
the head coach defended tom brady
is it possible that jimmy garoppolo
could take and and it was the belichick
scowl and it was the on to cincinnati
mantra over and over again he had a
coach for 20 years who would defend him
to the death against any and all critics
on the outside that's right doesn't have
that now you don't have that now
and i i think he
he knew or should have known what he was
signing up for when he went to tampa bay
but you know the walk off there after
two minutes and 21 seconds yes he's
frustrated with himself but i think he
also doesn't want to go down that path i
think he's trying to wall himself off
from even acknowledging yeah that he has
a coach who is willing to publicly do
something that his 20-year head coach
never did no i i i think there is
probably some of that you know i think
more than anything like brady's handling
himself you know like a pro there i
don't think there's any doubt about that
i mean he always says the right things
all of that you know i'll go back to
kind of what you said here to start this
little star uh this conversation before
we went to brady you talked about you
know aryans being with peyton manning
and ben roethlisberger and he's been
with other superstar quarterbacks this
this is different i'm sorry i mean as
much as awesome as i think peyton
manning is and all those things
man this is tom brady and just
the normal common fan who's just paying
to the paying attention the nfl to the
corner of their eye
oh oh these teams play each other this
week oh cool all right i'll sit down on
sunday and watch the games right that
just that that kind of fan they just see
tom brady tampa bay bucks they're
supposed to be in the super bowl super
bowl it's tom brady all i've known from
football the last 20 years as a casual
fan is tom brady new england patriots
they'll be in the final four brady is
one of those comments and i think that's
it's mounting on them down there and
yeah i don't think they expected to be
seven and five with this good of a
football team the defense everything
we've talked about so they're feeling it
and i'm sure brady is sick of this crap
a little bit there's no doubt um but
they all signed up for it and they can
cry me a river some other place and they
got to figure it out here in the last
four weeks of the year
but the other question is and you're
starting to hear the same things i've
been hearing will he sign up for it
again and the powers that be the people
who write the checks in tampa bay the
glazer family very interested in making
sure that no matter what else happens as
a result of this season
tommy chooses to come back
next year right people aren't going to
buy tickets when they can buy tickets
again to come see bruce aryan's coach
they're going to buy tickets and they're
going to be excited because tom brady is
the quarterback of the tampa bay
buccaneers and that is
maybe now that they're going to slow
down for a few days and you get out of
that week in and week out grind got a
game to get ready for you know if the
glazers want hey coach we need to talk
to y'all sorry i got a game to get ready
for well let's talk during the bye week
well the bye week's here
and and uh it could be that we here and
and this is informed speculation i think
is the best way to say it it could be we
hear a kindler gentler bruce aryans
coming out of this bye week because my
guess is at some point over the next
week someone named glazer is going to
make it very clear to him that in this
rock
paper scissors yeah i get it right that
time yeah rock paper scissors contest
um brady is the rock
and arianes is the scissors if it comes
down to it no doubt i mean
this is
tom brady two-year contract
year one
pandemic
didn't get to capitalize of all the
things tom brady in tampa bay i would
think and that's i think where we both
have heard it's hey we got to make sure
tom's really happy here in year one to
make sure we get year two and we could
capitalize on everything in our 50
million dollar investment and all those
type of things i definitely think that's
a real aspect of this
and i think too hey listen to what bruce
arian said the start of the segment i i
don't care who you are all-star team or
not whatever you need to practice you
need the off-season that did hurt them
and maybe these but this bye week will
help them kind of go back and and
formulate
an offense that they feel fits both of
them because that's to me the biggest
thing you know you talk you said the
word identity i don't know
really what their identity is it's oh
hey this series 210 tennis they run the
ball next series it's shotgun shotgun
shotgun shotgun we're gonna throw the
ball every play and you're just like man
wait what happened to the good offense
we saw last series and uh it's a little
all over the place and to me that's
where they need to get on the same page
and figure out how they want to attack
on that side of the ball it was former
teammate rob nikovich last week and an
appearance on espn who suggested that
brady needs a different head coach and
i i just i don't think what's happening
this year is sustainable into
2021 and if it continues it very well
could be that brady has a new head coach
next year and that head coach
will probably some be someone that he
signs off on or flat out
if they want to make this if they want
to make this work that's the way to make
it work brady's the center of the
universe right he has to say here's who
i want my coach to be yeah that that's
where i think no off-season and
everything hurt because
like exactly
you know brady's the king he's 43
he is limited in certain things he can
do
you know that you got to do things and
this is where new england was great for
him new england you know even though the
players weren't great they still had a
system
that could really utilize and capitalize
on all that brady had to offer here at
the late point of his career his ability
oh i'm in the spread okay blah blah blah
this coverage i know where to go oh and
mcdaniels and belichick have given me
lots of answers here to get six and
seven yard completions wherever that may
be on the field the bucks are not built
like that and that's where no off season
really hurt first off the receivers
aren't built to be the julian edelman
west welker danny amendola jitterbug
types mike evans is he's a big man chris
godwin's a bigger man you know they
don't have that as much and then the
offense and bruce arians in them they're
not like that so that's where
you know i think you might have to see
tampa bend a little bit as far as the
coaching staff to adhere to what brady
wants to do because that is what he does
best at this point of his career and
that does set him up i think for his
best chance of success
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports